قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون ان على
اوروبا ان تقلص ارتباطها بالولايات
المتحده وتتجنب الدخول في مواجهه محتمله
مع الصين بشان تايوان وحذر ماكرون العائد
من زياره الى الصين استمرت ثلاثه ايام مما
سماهم جرار اوروبا الى ازمات ليست ازماتها
ومن ان يصبح الاوروبيون مجرد اتباع في ملف
تايوان بين اجندات واشنطن ورد فعل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق جاءت دعوه
ماكرون الاوروبيين للناي بانفسهم عن سياسه
واشنطن تجاه تايوان وما الذي دفعه لاعلان
هذه الدعوه في هذا التوقيت وما حجم
الارتباط الاوروبي بالسياسه الامريكيه
تجاه تايوان في هذه اللحظه وما امكانيه
قبول بقيه دول اوروبا تقليص هذا الارتباط
في الفتره الراهنه وعلى اي نحو ستواجه
الولايات المتحده مثل هذه الدعوه وكيف
يمكن ان تنعكس على علاقاتها باوروبا وعلى
سياستها تجاه ملف تايوان
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات ادلى بها بعد عودته من زياره
دوله استمرت ثلاثه ايام الى الصين لقي
فيها بحسب التقارير ترحيبا حاره من الرئيس
سجن بينك قال الرئيس الفرنسي امانيويل
ماكرون ان على اوروبا ان تقلص ارتباطها
بالولايات المتحده وان تتجنب الدخول في
مواجهه محتمله مع الصين في قضيه تايوان
واضاف ماكرون في مقابله صحفيه انما وصفه
بالخطر الكبير بالنسبه لاوروبا هو ان تجد
نفسها تنجر الى ازمات ليست ازماتها ما
سيمنعها من بناء استقلاليتها الاستراتيجيه
وحذر من ان الاسوا هو الاعتقاد بان
الاوروبيين يجب ان يصبحوا اتباعا في هذا
الملف وان يستقوا اشاراتهم من اجنده
الولايات المتحده ورد الفعل الصيني
المبالغ فيه على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من باريس
المعهد الاوروبي لدراسات الامنيه
والاستشراف من ميريلاند تشارلز كابشن عضو
مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكيه
ومن الاسبق ومن جنيف الدكتور حسني عبادي
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جنيف
اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا ونبدا منك من باريس
سيد مانويل ما الذي
قصده ايمانويل ماكرون بهذه التصريحات وفي
اي سياق تاتي في هذا التوقيت
هو مقابله اجراها في الطائره
من الصين
مجله او جريده
واراد الرئيس ان يقدم خطابا يختلف قليلا
عن ما كان يقوله السابق عندما قال له معه
عندما كان
معندما قال يحتفظ
باستقلاليه استراتيجيه مقارنه مقارنه
بالبوصه الاستراتيجيه تحدثوا عنها في
الربيع الصيف الماضي
ويزدون ان وهو يريد في هذا انه
كان انتقادات هذه حول هذا المقال وهذا
المقال الذي جعل الرئيس
كانوا يقولون ان رئيس اولا رئيس لم يعد هو
رئيس الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي وهذا طبعا
موقف الفرنسي يخص فرنسا فقط كما يقولون
واذا
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه التي لم تقل نفس
الكلام ولا ننسى نبره وكانت رايها يميل
اكثر الى الى
التحدث
الصين وفيما تعرف بحقوق الانسان وما الى
ذلك وايضا الموضوع سياده تايوان هذا موضوع
يشغل اذهان بمعنى ان ان الموقف الفرنسي
اكد في الفقره السادسه من التصريح سته
نقاط فرنسا ان تذكره بالوحده الجغرافيه
والاراضي الصينيه
وبالتالي هذا ادى الى الكثير من التقدير
او اراء المختلفه حول
تدافع عنها مفوضيه الاوروبيه التي يقدمها
المقرون وبالتالي فهو قد قام بهذه الرحله
الى الصين والتي اعتبرت امر مخيب للامال
بالنسبه الاوروبيين سيد تشارلز كابتش ن
كيف يمكن ان تنظر الولايات المتحده الى
دعوه فرنسيه كهذه
اعتقد على ارجحناك ثلاثه ابعاد مختلفه
للتصرف ماكرون هذا في الصين من وجهه نظر
الى امريكا او اولا هذا هو يحب ان يلفت
الالتهاب يحب يكون اسمه في عناوين الاخبار
كانه السيد وبالتالي ليس من الغريب انه
لحد ما انه ماكرون يقوم
بالتاثير على العلاقات مع
اوكرانيا وايضا في العلاقات مع الصين
وثانيا اعتقد ان مقرون كما قال الزميله
لديه رؤيه ان يكون اكثر استقلاليه وان
تكون لاوروبا اكثر استقلالا مع وبالتالي
يخلق مسافه بين اوروبا والولايات المتحده
على عده جبهات منذ ذلك في اوكرانيا حيث ان
الفرنسيين
يركزون عن حل دبلوماسي وعلى الصين وايضا
بصراحه اعتقد هناك بعض اختلافات هامه ايضا
بين الاراء الاوروبيه الامريكيه فيما
يتعلق التعامل مع الصين
الالمان الفرنسيون وغيرهم اتوا برجال
اعمال معهم عندهم رؤيه ياتون الصين فهم
يرون ان عروضنا مفتوحه للتعامل التجاري مع
الصين في حين في الولايات المتحده
الراي هو في حرب بارده جدا لكن ان لابد ان
تكون بعض الابتعاد
عنوان الولايات المتحده لديها مهمه مصلحه
اكبر ومصالح استراتيجيه اكثر في منطقه
المحيط الهادي واسيا وبالنتيجه ذلك ان
هناك بعض التوترات حول طريقه مدى شده او
مدى صلابه الولايات المتحده فيما يتعلق
الموقف يتعلق بالطموحات السياسيه
والعسكريه للصين دعنا نسال السيد حسني
عبيدي عن الموقف الاوروبي ايضا يعني هذه
الدعوه برايك استاذ حسني كيف يمكن ان
تستقبلها بقيه الدول الاوروبيه
يعني يجب ان نذكر بانه
في الاسابيع المقبله كذلك سيزور ستزور
رئيس حكومه ايطاليا يعني ثالث اقتصاد
اوروبي في داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ثم زياره
لجزف بورا الثامن للشؤون الخارجيه اي ان
الدول الاوروبيه يعني في مرحله هروله
وليست يعني في النهايه لا يوجد هناك
اختلاف في وجهات النظر لكن لا اعتقد هناك
اختلاف كبير لان ماكرون طرح اعتقد قضيه
اساسيه يعني مقاربه جديده تعتمد على ثلاث
عناصر العنصر العنصر الاول هو تفكيك
الازمات انه لا يمكن الربط ما بين ازمه
اوكرانيا وكذلك والعلاقه مع الصين العنصر
العنصر الثاني هو الوحده الجغرافيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي وليس العكس اي اننا
باوكرانيا نعم كما قال ماكرون لكن
اوكرانيا بعيده على اتحاد الاوروبي
والنقطه الثالثه انما كره وصل الى
قناع نفادها بانه من اجل الوصول الى حل
اوكرانيا التي هي فعلا مشكله اوروبيه لابد
ان تكون هناك علاقه مع علاقه جيده مع
بالاضافه للعناصر التي تعرفونها جيدا يعني
حجم التجاره ما بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
والصين فاقف 856 مليار 20 في المئه من
حاجات من السلع التي تحتاجها اوروبا تاتي
من الصين فهناك قناعه فعلا بانه يجب ان
نفكك بين ازمه اوكرانيا وازمه الصين وانا
لا اعتقد ان اوروبا يعني ستظهر مقاومه
كبيره المقاومه تاتي بريطانيا بريطانيا
خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك خلاف وجهات
النظر لكن اعتقد الان رئيس ماكرون اصطحب
معه او يعني جاءت كذلك السيده
حتى يعطي بعدا اوروبيا وليس فرنسيين الان
القضيه في يد ماكرون اذا استطاع فعلا
اقناع الاتحاد الاوروبي بانه لابد من
الحفاظ على علاقه جيده مع الصين من اجل
حزمه اوكرانيا ولانه اوروبا لا يمكن لها
ليس لديها القدره ان تفتح جبهه جديده مع
الصين بالاضافه الى الجبهه الاوكرانيه
التي تكلفها الكثير طيب يعني عندما يطالب
بمن ويل ماكرون بفك الارتباط بين الدول
الاوروبيه والاتحاد الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده فيما يخص السياسه تجاه
تايوان السؤال هنا الى اي مدى يوجد تماهي
وتطابق بين السياسه الامريكيه والاوروبيه
تجاه تايوان
المشكله لان الرئيس ماكرون يخطئ حين يعتبر
ان الموقف سوف يكون مختلفا عن الموقف
الامريكي لعدد من الاسباب اولا هل الذي
صار يعد الان
22 دوله عضو صرح بعكس ما قاله ماكرون حيث
قال ان الحلف
خلال
قمه
فيروس في شهر يونيو
فيه عدد من الدول التي تركز على اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه واستراليا
قد اجتمع بالرئيس الكوري ورئيس
الوزراء الاستراليه والرئيسه الياباني او
رئيس وزراء الياباني كذلك وكما اسلفت كان
هناك الكثير من النقاشات والاسئله
فكره ان يتحدث ماكرون باسم اوروبا لا يمكن
ان يتحدث باسم اوروبا فنحن نتحدث عن
السويد التي تتراس المجلس الاوروبي حتى
شهر يوليو ومن ثم اسبانيا ومن ثم بيلجيكا
وبيدروس سانشيز توجه الى بيتين قبل ايام
من ماكرون وكذلك نلحظ ان اولفشولز ايضا
الالماني قال
او انه
ظهر بيت جينج قبل مكروه في شهر يناير اذا
ليس هناك جبهه موحده من حيث السياسه
الاوروبيه تجاهها الصين نحن لدينا
عشرون عاما من السياسه الاستراتيجيه
كذلك بالنسبه الى العلاقات مع روسيا
والعلاقات مع الصين لا يمكن ان يكون
الموقف موحدا مع الولايات المتحده هناك
دول داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي التي هي اكثر
ميلا الى التفكير من وجهه نظر حلف النيتو
اكثر من الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكيف يمكن ان تنظر واشنطن الى ذلك
تعلمون اعتقد
ان هناك مشاكل او قضايا يتعلق باوروبا
بفصل بينهما بنظريا مكرون محق بانه في
نهايه المطاف الامر يطلب ضغوطا من الشيل
على البوتين لانهاء حرب اوكرانيا انا
اعتقد ان مقرون
صادق لاوانه وهو
قد ذهب الى موسكو
واعتقد انه في بدايه السنه عندما يبدا
الهجوم الاوكراني انذاك ربما الضغوط
الصينيه على روسيا قد تؤتي بنا الى نهايه
دبلوماسيه للحرب اما فيما يتعلق بتايوان
اعتقد هناك اختلاف جوهري الولايات المتحده
واوروبا في اوروبا لديه قوات قليله في
المنطقه الفرنسيه الذي انبضعت اعلاف وبعض
البرامج الحربيه
ومعظميه حضور وجود استراتيجي في تايوان
وبالتالي كانت نتيجه ذلك المزيد المسؤوليه
تقع على عاتق الولايات المتحده للتعامل مع
الوضع الموجود في بحر جنوب الصين وللتعامل
مع الطموحات الصينيه المتزايده اما اوروبا
فليس لديها مصلحه في ان ترى حربا حول
تايوان او استداء الصين على تايوان ولكن
ذلك في الحقيقه
يعتبر تامر مهم بالنسبه
تحيه ذلك ان اوروبا
ركز فقط على الامن الاوروبي في حين ولا
يفمده لا يتركز فقط على اوروبا بل تركز
ايضا في الوقت ذاته تحاول ان توجه نحو
اسيا وان توصل بالمزيد القواتها الى مسرح
عمليات المحيط الهادي واسيا دكتور حسني
عبيدي كان هناك تقارب كبير مؤخرا خاصه
فيما يخص اوكرانيا بين الولايات المتحده
واوروبا هل ترى ان العلاقه الاوروبيه
الامريكيه يمكن ان تتاثر سلبا بالنظر الى
هذه التصريحات الفرنسيه
يعني من الصعب لان الدول الاوروبيه لنقل
الدول الفاعله داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي تريد
الفصل ما بين الملف الاوكراني وملفات اخرى
للولايات المتحده مصطلحات مهمه جدا في في
تصريح الرئيس ماكرون هي قضيه مثلا قضيه
الحريه قضيه منذ خمس سنوات وهو خطاب رئيس
ماكرون في جامعه اسطنبول ويحاول يقول بانه
اوكرانيا هي قضيه عادله ولابد للدول
الاوروبيه ان تستمر في دعم اوكرانيا لكنه
عندما ياتي الموضوع الى علاقات الولايات
المتحده مع الصين في قضيه تايوان فهنا
يتعتقد تاتي النقطه اساسيه ويمكن ان نقول
بان الرئيس مكروه اعاده تقييمه للعلاقه مع
الصين بعد هذه الزياره هو راى في النهايه
بان الصين محقه في راي في عندما تقول
بانها ليست مساعده للموقف الغربي لماذا
الغرب يريد من الصين ان تقوم بدور مساعد
والضغط على الضغط على روسيا في حين ان
الصين هي اصلا تريد ان تكون عنصر فاعل في
هذا النظام الجديد او قطب جديد والرئيس
مكرونه يقول انها في النهايه يعني ما
تقوله الصين هو يصب في خانه الدول
الاوروبيه لماذا كذلك اوروبا لا يكون
لديها كذلك دور في هذه المرحله الخروج من
الاصطفاف الروسي الامريكي وابراز بمساعده
ابراز اوروبا قطب جديد لا يكونوا مكملا
واستعمل كلمه تابعا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهذا اعتقد قراءه يعني جريئه
للموقف الفرنسي يعني الى مدى يمكن ان
تتبع الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا الموقف
لكن اعتقد ان مهمه جدا لانه في النهايه لا
يمكن للدول الاوروبيه ان يكون لديها دور
في الحرب الاوكرانيه اذا لم تستطيع ان
تربح ثقه الصين باعتبار ان العلاقه ما بين
بيكين واشنطن في يعني في ازمه كبيره تحول
دون منع الصين لهذا الدور الايجابي في
الحرب الاوكرانيه قلت قبل قبل قليل ان
تصريحات مانويل ماكرون لا تمثل جميع
الاوروبيين ولكن ماذا عن العلاقات
الفرنسيه الامريكيه هل يمكن ان تتاثر سلبا
بتصريحاته هذه التي تدعو الى فك الارتباط
مع السياسه الامريكيه تجاه تايوان
المهم الا وهو النقطه الرابعه من التصريح
حيث هناك 51 نقطه حيث قال ان الجبهه
الجنوبيه
مطلوب منها تعزيز التعاون مع القياده
الفرنسيه لمنطقه اسيا الهادئ وهذا من شاني
ان يطرح الكثير من الاسئله بالنسبه الى
العلاقات مع الاصول الامريكيه السابع
ويحملها على التعاون العسكري مع الصين هذه
نقطه مهمه يجب ان نليها اهتماما كبيرا لكي
نفهم طبيعه هذا العلاقه التي يتحدث عنها
يجب ان لا ننسى ان هذا الاعلان ياتي في
لحظه مهمه منذ اسابيع في سانتياغو فان دول
اليابان واستراليا والهند والولايات
المتحده اجتمعت بدون وجود فرنسا بينما
فعلا لديها طموحات مثل الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي ان تكون مؤثره في منطقه
اسيا الهادئ كذلك منذ سنتين سنت
المتحده وبريطانيا العظمى واستراليا
اخر
عفوا
حيث فكت على الارتباط بين فرنسا واستراليا
لتوفير سفن
وذلك لصالح عدد من الغواصات النوويه
وبالتالي يجب ان لا ننسى انها ماكرون قد
اخذ في الاعتبار الاعذار التي تتبناها
الولايات المتحده بالنسبه الى هذا تعنى في
الظاهر التي راتها فرنسا بعد قطع العلاقه
التجاريه العسكريه بين فرنسا واستراليا
ولكن هذا امر لا يزال عالقا في دهن
القطاع الصناعي العسكريه الذي يرغب طبعا
في تعزيز العلاقات التجاريه الصناعيه مع
الصين كان هناك هدف اخر هذه الزياره مع
عدد من الطائرات التي تمت تم بيعها مع عدد
من الطوافات لشركه اربيس التي ايضا تم
بيعها بالمقابل سيد تشارلز كابشن هل يمكن
لدعوات كهذه
التي استمعنا اليها من الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرون ان تؤثر على السياسه
الامريكيه تجاه تايوان
انا اعتقد انه بشكل عام العلاقات فرنسيه
الامريكيه قويه جدا
ولطالما كانت تتعزز بعد حرب اوكرانيا وان
اوروبا والولايات المتحده في الصوره
الكبرى يقتربان بعض ما اكثر فاكثر ما
يتعلق بالصين وليس ابعد وابعد رغم ان
اختلافات ما زالت قائمه ولكن اعتقد فعلا
بان الراي العام في فرنسا ومن اوروبا بشكل
عام هو ان الولايات المتحده ربما تدفع
بشكل اكبر من اللازم على الصين
بافتراض اننا بدك نتوجه نحو حرب بارده وان
هذه المواجهه مع حول التايوان موجوده
محتمله جدا واعتقد ان اوروبا تحاول ان
تشغل تحمل الفرامل هذا الامر وتقول
لواشنطن دعونا نحاول نتصرف بطريقه اكثر
علاقات مبناءه وا مع الصين قبل ان نستيقظ
يوما ما ونحن في حرب بارده جديده اليست
بين الصين لان الصين وروسيا سويه واعتقد
النواشط ما تزال تحاول ان تجد طريقها الى
الامام فعلا شاهدنا بعض الجهد للبدء بحوار
استراتيجي مع بيجين ثم توقف ذلك بعد مساله
منطاد الصيني الذي طار فوق الولايات
المتحده لكن اعتقد يبعث رساله مهمه دعونا
ان ناخذ نفسا عميقا ونتوقف قليلا ونرى هل
نستطيع ان ننظم التنافس مع الصين بطريقه
او باتجاه اكثر ايجابيه شكرا جزيلا
القومي الامريكي الاسبق من باريس مانويل
رئيس المعهد الاوروبي لدراسات الامن
والاستشراف ومن جنيه الدكتور حسني عبيدي
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جنيفا
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]